desde el pasado viernes 21 de enero
méxico comenzó a exigir el visado a los
venezolanos para ingresar a su
territorio con el objetivo de disminuir
la llegada de migrantes irregulares
desde ese país sudamericano hacia eeuu
la entrada en vigor de esta medida
migratoria del gobierno andrés manuel
lópez obrador coincide con reportes
sobre centenares de venezolanos sin
admitidos en los aeropuertos de mexico y
la imposibilidad de embarcarse en vuelos
hacia el país norteamericano desde otras
naciones como por ejemplo panamá la
prensa venezolana ha reflejado varias
denuncias de viajeros que no pudieron
llegar a mexico incluso antes de la
fecha tope para ingresar sin visado
reclaman que todos sus documentos
estaban en regla y que se encontraban
parados en pésimas condiciones en
distintos terminales aéreos alrededor
del mundo quiero saludar entonces a
nuestra segunda mitad del día ya está
maría clara a robayo investigadora del
observatorio de venezuela de la
universidad del rosario en colombia
gracias maya clara por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
preguntó cómo afecta esta nueva medida a
los venezolanos tanto para los que
usaban méxico como un país de tránsito
para llegar a si eeuu o quedarse en ese
país y para los que iban de turismo
bueno muy buenos días a todos en efecto
la navidad tiene grandes implicaciones
para esta población venezolana
veremos un fenómeno desde el año pasado
de un aumento de la migración que estaba
viviendo en venezuela en color
venezolana que está en venezuela en
colombia en perú y que obviamente ante
el cambio de política migratoria cuando
el gobierno llega el gobierno by
dentales con una mirada mucho más
humanista y mucho más abierta con
grandes promesas hacia los migrantes
pues esto empieza a generar una
migración en aumento para agosto del
2021 se hablaba más de 40 mil
venezolanos que han llegado al
territorio norteamericano es un
escenario que se ha venido agudizando en
los últimos meses y que efectivamente
viene en crecimiento cuando los
venezolanos no se les pedía visa hacia
méxico ahora la reciente
anuncio pues efectivamente es un anuncio
por un lado que fue muy poco con muy
poco tiempo anunciado fue anunciado a
comienzos de enero entonces muchas
personas no se enteraron o ya habían
comprado boletos de viaje había pagado
estadías en hoteles y allí hay una serie
de peticiones que se están dando hoy a
través de la embajada de mexico para que
logren para que logren llegar a eeuu sin
embargo está esta esta respuesta ha sido
negativa
igualmente en la visa que tiene un costo
de 50 dólares más y además son personas
que tienen que respaldar una solidez
financiera
sabemos que ese tipo de requisitos es
muy difícil para esta población
venezolana teniendo en cuenta que el
contexto interno interno de su país pues
efectivamente sin duda en la medida que
ha tomado
méxico y pues también se puede ver con
una medida conjunta con eeuu va a
reducir el número de migrantes que están
llegando a ser llegaba en los últimos
meses pero sin lugar a dudas no debemos
desconocer que esta migración venezolana
no disminuirá y quienes aún así por
llegar a ver hasta méxico eeuu lo van a
hacer ahora en condiciones más
irregulares van a tener el informe
regular a méxico lo que generará más
abusos
más movimientos de res de trata de
personas y muchísima más vulnerabilidad
a los vida usted habla maría clara de
esa solvencia económica que tienen que
demostrar los venezolanos estamos
hablando de aproximadamente unos 2500
dólares al menos en sus cuentas
bancarias para ver si entonces el
gobierno mexicano le entregue esa visa
pero entonces hablemos también de otra
arista que tiene esta problemática maria
clara y ese cómo afecta esta medida a la
familia venezolana hablo por supuesto de
los venezolanos que tienen familia en
méxico que ahora tendrán más trabas para
poder ir a visitar a sus familiares no
necesariamente
influye y afecta a estos venezolanos que
si quiere emigrar sino también a estos
venezolanos que tienen su familia que no
tiene ninguna ningún sentido de ninguna
intención de quedarse en ese país sin
lugar a dudas la migración venezolana
hoy alcanza una cifra cerca de 6
millones de personas cerca del
70% de esas de esos 6 millones de
personas están en latinoamérica y méxico
es uno de los destinos no uno de los
destinos principales pero si es un
destino de recepción migratoria de la
población venezolana entonces allí habrá
diferentes efectos por un lado como como
bien se mencionó las familias van a
tener implicaciones directas negativas
que no van a poder viajar recurrente
visitar a sus familiares seguramente
también haya personas que pensaban
radicarse hace rectificación familiar
para reunirse con sus con sus familiares
en méxico y pues también se al tema de
las remesas no muchas familias hoy en
venezuela dependen de las remesas como
solvencia económica diaria entonces allí
las las implicaciones son son preguntas
recordemos que la migración siempre cada
vez más es más variadas son diferentes
flujos y pues evidentemente méxico
principalmente en un país de tránsito
para muchas personas que iban para eeuu
pero como conservo lo menciona no
podemos olvidar que también son pues en
un país de atracción migratoria
importante maría clara también de los 98
países que se le exige la visa a los
venezolanos para entrar 22 se encuentran
en la región de américa latina y el
caribe que lectura le podemos dar a esto
bueno pues es complejo
las condiciones para estar mirando la
población venezolana son diversas pero
hay una gran y hay una altísima
vulnerabilidad
dentro de estos micro fenómenos que se
dieron de las migraciones y eeuu está lo
que sucedido en colombia con la frontera
con panamá por ejemplo en donde la
mayoría es una migración haitiana pero
también allí hay algunos migrantes
venezolanos hemos visto que los
migrantes venezolanos se han venido
adhiriendo un poco las dinámicas de
movilidad humana que ya existían
previamente en la región en el caso de
colombia mencionó el tema de panamá de
una migración extra regional pero
también por ejemplo en el caso de méxico
los migrantes venezolanos hoy se
incrustan dentro de estas caravanas que
ya llevaban varios años dirigiéndose por
centroamérica hacia estados unidos en
condiciones como lo digo de altísimo
peligro en la mayoría mediados por redes
muy peligrosas de tráfico y trata de
personas sí y pues esto es una una
realidad que no se le porque no puede
ser ajena a los gobiernos maría clara ya
por último para finalizar nuestra
conversación sobre este tema que por
supuesto nos vamos a quedar aquí
muchísimo tiempo hablando pero se nos
acaba el tiempo acá el programa colombia
puede exigirle una visa a los
venezolanos estarían los planes del
gobierno en hacer esto teniendo en
cuenta que también colombia es el primer
país que recibe a estos venezolanos
migrantes
bueno en este momento colombia adelanta
un proceso diferente de regularización
que es el estatuto tiempo de protección
que busca regularizar ahora a cerca de
un millón 800 mil migrantes con vocación
de permanencia digamos que en este
momento es decir el interés del gobierno
evidentemente luego de que suceda este
gran proceso de regularización que sin
duda ocupará varios años pues no sabemos
hacia dónde tienda el tipo de política
migratoria con con venezuela sin embargo
no debemos olvidar que es una migración
fronteriza una migración una frontera de
2.200 kilos dos mil 217 kilómetros muy
porosa y será muy difícil tener medidas
tan fuertes como como visados con como
visados que intenten realmente contener
con seguramente con muy poco éxito la
migración venezolana a colombia y como
sí también lo dijo la visa tampoco es un
impedimento para que estos migrantes
llegan a su destino lo harán entonces
por vías irregulares y ahí si se
complica entonces mucho más la cosa para
esto son migrantes ya en estado de mucha
vulnerabilidad maría clara gracias por
su tiempo por estar nosotros en directo
américa de francés y 4 y analizar todo
este tema que afecta a muchísimas
personas en nuestra región y también a
los gobiernos específicamente por
supuesto a los venezolanos